ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนครูฟ้าวันนี้วันอะไร
คะวันนี้วันศุกร์ค่ะ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันศุกร์ที่
27 เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
พฤษภาคมปีพตอะไรคะอีผช
ปีคศอะไรคะปีคศอะ
2022 ค่ะค่ะเมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะเมื่อ
วานนี้วันพฤหัสบดีวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
วันที่ 26 เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
พฤษภาคมปีพ.ศ.อะไรคะปีพต 2  5  6 ห้า
ปีคศอะไรคะปีคศ 2  022 ค่ะค่ะพรุ่งนี้วัน
อะไรคะพรุ่งนี้วันเสาร์
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
28 เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
พฤษภาคม EP พ.ศต.ค.ปีพตต 2  0
2565 ปีคศปีค.ศ
2022 ค่ะตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะครูฟ้า
ตอนนี้ช่วงเวลา
เที่ยงเที่ยงกี่นาทียี่สิบห้านาที
ยี่สิบห้านาทีนะคะก็ตอนนี้เป็นเวลากลาง
วันเนาะ
ราคา wanna กินข้าวหรือยังคะกินข้าวแล้ว
ค่ะค่ะครูป๊ากินข้าวหรือยังคะรูปฟ้ากิน
ข้าวแล้วค่ะขอกูกินอะไร
ครูฟ้ากิน
นี่ไหนมีให้ดูหรออ๋อมีรูปให้ดูว่าหนีครู
ฟ้ากินอะไร
ผู้ฟ้ากินถ้าจะตอนแทน
แค่นั้นแฮแนนมาหรือยังคะมาหรือยังเธอ
ช่วงเนี้ยอะไรนักเรียนรอ
ขอเพลงนี้มาทำไมให้ได้แป๊บนึงข้าวเหนียว
หมูปิ้งนะคะอันนี้นึงยิ่ง
เป็นหมูใช่ไหมจ้าใช่ไม่ฟ้า
อันนี้หมูปิ้งนะคะหมูใส่ที่ฟ้าที่อยู่ใน
หมูข้าวเหนียวสีขาวและเขาเหนียวชายหนูฟ้า
คะครูหญิงมีคำถามถามว่าอะไรถามว่าในใน 7
วันเนี่ยนะคะ 7 วันหรือว่า 1 อาทิตย์
เนี่ย 7 วันหรือว่า 1 อาทิตย์แหละนะคะครู
ฟ้ากินข้าวเหนียวหมูปิ้งบ่อยแค่ไหน
มือ
กินทุกวันก็คือกิน 7 วันเลยน่ากินทุกวัน
บีกินบ่อยๆไม่ได้กินทุกวันแต่ว่ากินบ่อยๆ
กินบ่อยกัน
5 วัน
ประมาณ 5 วันซี
กินแบบนานๆครั้ง
นั้นนานกิน 1 ครั้งใน 7 วันก็อาจจะประมาณ
3 วันเนาะประมาณ 3 วันหรือดีตอนนี้ไม่
ได้นะคะดีนะคือ 0 ไม่กินไม่ค่อยได้กิน
ไม่กินเลยอันนี้น่าจะไม่ใช่และไม่ใช่
เพราะกูฟ้ากินข้าวเหนียวหมูปิ้งไปนะคะหา
[เพลง]
กินพูดความจริงทุกวัน
หรือว่านานๆครั้งตั้งครั้งคู่ฟ้ากินข้าว
เหนียวร้านปิ้ง
บ่อยๆ
บ่อยๆก็คือเราเรามาถ้าใน 7 วันครูป๊าก็
กินประมาณ
5 วัน 5 วันชัย
ผู้หญิงไม่กินข้าวเหนียวหมูปิ้งหรอใช่ค่ะ
ถ้าครูหญิงก็คือข้อดีค่ะพอดีไม่กินไม่ได้
กินเลยใน 7 วันเนี่ยผู้หญิงไม่ได้กินข้าว
เหนียวหมูปิ้งเลยหรือว่าใน 1 เดือนก็ไม่
ได้กินเลยผู้หญิงใน 1 ปี
ใน 1 ปีถ้า 1 ปีครูหญิงกินข้าวเหนียวหมู
ปิ้งก็
นานๆน่าจะเป็นข้อ 4 นะนานๆ 1 ครั้ง
นานๆค่ะหนึ่งก็มีหนึ่งหลังเออหนึ่งปี
หนึ่งครั้งนะคะสายเพราะวันนี้เนี่ยครู
หญิงก็จะมีคำถามมาถามครูฟ้า
รถเกี่ยวข้าวกู
ว่าครูฟ้าทำอะไร
ฟ้าทำอะไรแล้วก็บ่อยแค่ไหนนะบ่อยแค่ไหน
อ่ะอันนี้ละกันครูฝาเนี่ยกูฟ้าเขาจะเล่น
โซเชียลมีเดียนะคะช่องคือแต่
โซเชียลมีเดียก็จะมี Twitter  Facebook
Instagram  YouTube
ทินเดอร์ไม่ได้เล่นค่ะแต่ว่าเราไม่ถามว่า
เล่นบ่อยแค่ไหนนะคุยอยากจะถามว่าเวลาครู
ฟาเลนเอา Facebook และกันส่วนนี้ Media
Social  Media อะไรก็ได้ครูฟ้าเนี่ย
โพสต์ในโซเชี่ยลมีเดียใช่ไหมอะนี้ก็จะมี
โทรศัพท์แล้วก็จะมีทวิตเตอร์อย่างนี้
ทวิตเตอร์เนี้ยค่ะโอ๊ยใช่ไหมอันนี้ฟ้า
แล้วก็ดื้อ post หรือโซเชียลมีเดียอ่ะ
เนี่ยบ่อยแค่ไหนไหม 1
ปุกวันหนึ่งหายรอยตรงนี้เลยนะคะอันนี้ก็
คือใน 7 วันเหมือนกันนะนักเรียน
ก็คือคือทุกวัน
2 บ่อยๆโพสบ่อยๆแต่ไม่ใช่ทุกวันก็จะ
ประมาณ
4-5 วันเนาะอันนี้ก็ถือว่าบ่อยนะ
หรือว่า 3 นานๆโพสต์ 1 ครั้งก็จะมา 2  3
วัน
หรือ 4 ก็คือแบบหนึ่งอาทิตย์เนี่ยไม่ได้
โพสต์เลยไม่เล่นโพสต์โซเชียลมีเดียเลย
อันครูฟ้าเนี่ยโค้ชโซเชียลมีเดียบ่อยแค่
ไหนใน 7 วันครูปลาเนี่ย
ถ้าโตเชี่ยว Media
ทุกนานๆครั้งล่ะอ๋อโค้ชนะนักเรียนไม่ได้
เล่นนะครับโพสต์ปะเนี่ยนานๆโพสต์ 1 ครั้ง
ใช่หาพ่อสมมุติถ้าครูฟ้าเล่น
Facebook ใช่ไหม
ถ้ากูฟ้าเล่น Facebook หรือ
Twitter เนี่ย
กูฟ้าไม่ค่อยโพสนะกูว่าจะไลค์
รีทวิต
ความไม่โพสดู
ครูหญิงร้าผู้หญิงเนี่ยโพสต์ Social
Media ทุกวันบ่อยๆนานๆครั้งหรือไม่โพสต์
เลย
ถ้าใน 7 วันราคาใน 7 วันน่ะค่ะใน 7 วันนะ
ไม่โพสเฮ้ยเฮ้ยก็
ทำไม
ผู้หญิงก็กดไลค์เท่านั้นไม่โพสต์ล่ะนิ
โซเชียลมีเดียส่วนตัวนะส่วนตัวไม่ใช่
โซเชียลมีเดียที่เป็นครูหญิงผู้หญิงมี 2
หรือเป็นตัวเตี้ย Media ของผู้หญิงกับที่
เป็นโซเชียลมีเดีย
ที่มีเพื่อน Private อ่ะ Pirate นะมึงตัว
แหละส่วนตัวเนี่ยก็คือไม่โพสต์เลยใน 7
วันทางโหผู้หญิง
ดู
ข้อต่อไปของเอามาหาถามครูฟังว่าไง 1
เดือนใน 1 เดือนละกันเนาะเอา 1 เดือนบ้าง
ถึงเดือนนะคะครูฟ้าเนี่ยทำอาหาร
อันนี้ก็จะมียังๆใช่ไหมมีกระทะมีตะหลิว
แล้วก็พี่ฟ้าอยู่ไหนล่ะกูฟ้าหาย
[เพลง]
รหะครูฟ้า
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยทำอาหารกินเองบ่อยแค่ไหนใน 1
เดือน
หนึ่งทุกวันฝ่ายค่ะทุกวันทุกวันก็คืออัน
นี้แล้วกันเลยเนาะเป็นร้อยเปอร์เซ็นต์ทุก
วันอ่า
หรือว่าอันนี้ก็แบบเอ้อซัก 80% แล้วกัน
เนาะบ่อยๆนะคะหรือว่าอันนี้ซัก
50% นานๆทำ 1 ครั้งค่ะหรือว่าสิแต่ข้อ
ที่ 4 ศูนย์เปอร์เซ็นต์ก็คือ 1 เดือนไม่
ทำอาหารกินเลย
ครูฟ้าทำอาหารกินเองใน
โรงเรียนนานๆครั้งล่ะนานครั้งแล้ว 1
เดือนครูฟ้าทำอาหารกินเองประมาณกี่วันนาน
ๆเพื่อนครูฟ้าทำอาหารกินเองประมาณ 1  One
Piece นี่ก็นานๆครั้งเหมือนกันอันนี้ไม่
นานๆครั้งก็กูฟ้ากูก็ต้องแก้ต่อมาจากอัน
นี้ค่ะผู้ค้าต้องบอกว่าน้อยครั้งค่ะ
น้องน้อยครั้งประมาณค่ะ 10 เปอร์เซ็นต์นะ
คะผู้ฟ้าก็คือน้อยครั้งไม่ใช่นานๆครั้งใน
ว่าครูฟ้าเนี่ยขี้เกียจ
ไปเอาทำ
ถ้าอย่างนั้นครูฟ้าไม่ทำอาหารใช่ไหมในใน 1
เดือนครูฟ้าเนี่ย
สั่ง crap สมัยไฟฟ้ามีโทรศัพท์แล้วก็มี
แอพพลิเคชั่นแกร๊บรอแป๊บเนี่ยเป็น
เดลิเวอรี่สั่งอาหารเดลิเวอรี่นะคะ
ใน 1 เดือนเนี่ยครูฟ้าเนี่ยสั่งอาหารจาก
แกร๊บบ่อยแค่ไหน
ทุกวัน
ก็ไม่ทุกวันแต่บ่อยๆก็นานๆครั้งน้อยครั้ง
หรือว่าไม่เลยไม่สั่งเลยใน 1 เดือนรูปฟ้า
เนี่ย
มีสั่งแกร๊บนะ
[เพลง]
ทุกวันค่ะ
xxx
ทุกวันคือ hbd อะไร
วันปกติเลยเนาะทุบมายทุกวันงานทุกวัน
อย่างผู้หญิงโอ้โหว่าชอบนักแร็พ
เดลิเวอรี่ผู้หญิงราคะผู้หญิงเนี่ย
อันนี้ครูหญิงนะอ้าวถึงตัวสีเขียวนะคะ
เป็นกะโมราสีเขียว
อ่อนอันนี้กระทะ
อ๋อรู้ฟ้าจะถามเกี่ยวกับผู้หญิงทำอาหาร
กินเองใช่ไหมใช่ผู้หญิงทำอาหารกินเองไหม
อันนี้คือหญิงทำอาหารกินเองนะคะหรือผู้
หญิงเนี่ยมีโทรศัพท์มันจะหรือไม่ได้สิผู้
หญิงทำอาหารกินเอง
ทุกวัน
แค่ไหนบ่อยแค่ไหนเออ
อาหารกินเองทุกวันไหมมีบ่อยๆนานๆครั้ง
น้อยครั้งไม่เลยนะหา
ครูหญิงทำอาหารกินเองน่าจะเป็น
นานๆครั้งอาไม่ใช่น้อยครั้งหรอคะออกมา
อย่างน้อยเนี่ย 1 เดือนเนี่ยผู้หญิงก็ทำ
อาหารกินเองประมาณ
10-12 วันนะอ๋ออ่อนี่ฟ้าธานีผู้หญิงจ่าย
ค่ะนั่นแหละก็นานๆครั้งทำอาหารกินเอง
แล้วผู้หญิงอ่า
ใช้แอพพลิเคชั่น Grab ไหมคะใช้ค่ะครูฟ้า
ผู้หญิงเนี่ยสั่งแตรป
บ่อยแค่ไหน
บ่อยๆ
ไม่ใช่ทุกวันนะงงวันแหละไม่ใช่ค่ะพี่ยัง
ไม่ได้สั่งทุกวันนะแต่ว่าบ่อยๆก็คือ 80%
น่ะบ่อยๆนะคะนักเรียนต่อไปค่ะครูฟ้าผู้
หญิงยังมีคำถามมาถามครูปาอีกท่ามว่าอะไร
คะอ่ะครูน้อง 3 ทำเมื่อฉันไปแล้วสั่ง crap
ไปแล้วคำถามเขานะก็ยังเกี่ยวกับอาหารนะคะ
ว่าครูฟ้าเนี่ยภูฟ้าอยู่บ้านสมัยอยู่บ้าน
เนี่ยคนไทยส่วนใหญ่และก็กินอาหารที่บ้าน
แต่ก็มีบางครั้งเนี่ยเราไปกินอาหารนอก
บ้านอะไรก็จะมีโต๊ะ
สวยแล้วก็มีเก้าอี้เนี่ยที่เป็นร้านอาหาร
ใกล้ไปครูฟ้าเนี่ยไปกินข้าวนอกบ้านก็คือ
ไปกินที่ร้านอาหารใน 1 เดือนบ่อยแค่ไหน
ไปกินทุกวันบ่อยๆนานๆครั้งน้อยครั้งหรือ
ว่าไม่ค่อยได้ไปเลยอ่ะเออไปกินอาหารข้าง
นอกบ้าน
ครูฟ้าไปกินอาหาร
ออกนอกบ้าน 1 เดือน
หรือ 1 ปีก็ได้ไหม 1 เดือนน้อยไปไหมเอา 1
เดือน 1 เดือนคิดว่าน่าจะ
นานๆครั้งไหมนานๆครั้งเดือนนึงก็ประมาณ
5 ครั้งหกครั้งหรือว่าสิบครั้งก็ได้นะไง
ค่ะมันก็จะไปประมาณนี้นะคะ
5 ครั้งมือจ่ายก็นานๆครั้งเนาะผู้หญิง
ล่ะคะผู้หญิงออกไปกินอาหารนอกบ้านไหม
เดือนนี้ไปแล้วก็หินไปกินอาหารนอกบ้าน
บ่อยแค่ไหนผู้หญิงไปน่าจะน้อยครั้งค่ะครู
ฟ้าน้อยครั้งประมาณผู้หญิงน่าจะไปแค่สอง
ครั้ง
สองครั้งเองนะ 2 ครั้งน้อยครั้งนะคะไม่
ค่อยได้ไปกินอาหาร
ถ้าชอบบ้าน
เมียต่อไปค่ะต่อปลาอีกได้หักรินครูฟ้าไม่
เอากินอาหารแล้วใช่ไหมเราทำงานเนี่ยก็มี
เงินสมัยมีเงินมีเงินเนี่ยไปซื้ออาหาร
แล้วจะว่าเราเนี่ยบางครั้งก็ซื้อของจะไป
ซื้อของที่ไม่ใช่อาหารอาจจะเป็นเสื้อยาง
มัดผมน่ะ
กางเกงกางเกง
ลิปซีแต่ละหรือว่าเกมคือเกมซื้อตุ๊กตา
ซื้อของใน 1 เดือนนะ 1 เดือนเนี่ยครูฟ้า
ซื้อของจะเป็นเสื้อผ้านะคะ
ลิปสติก
ซื้อของบ่อยแค่ไหนอยู่ใน 1 เดือน
คือ
ครูฟ้าซื้อของ
ว่าจะเป็นแบบ
แก้วน้ำสวยๆใช่ไหมอ่ะซื้อของโอ้นานๆครั้ง
นานๆครั้งงอ่ะซื้อของนานๆครั้งหนึ่งเดือน
เนี่ย 1 เดือนครูฟ้าซื้อของประมาณ
ประมาณ
4 ครั้งเองสีครั้งนานๆครั้งน้อยครั้งไม่
ได้นักฟ้าเออแต่ว่าน่าจะนานๆครั้งนั่น
แหละนานครั้งหน้านานๆครั้ง
ผู้หญิงละฮะผู้หญิงเนี่ย 1 เดือนผู้หญิง
ซื้อของบ่อยแค่ไหนคุยซื้อของบ่อยไม่ใช่
ทุกวันนะคะนักเรียนทุกวันก็บอกเถอะ
ดอกไม้บ่อยๆซื้อบ่อยๆนะคะแอพพลิเคชั่น
shopee อย่างเงี้ยซื้อออนไลน์นะซื้อบ่อย
ๆแต่ถ้าซื้อไปออกไปออกไปข้างนอกแล้วซื้อ
โอ้โห้
น้อยครั้งค่ะแต่ถ้าซื้อออนไลน์สวย www
dot  dot  com ใน of บ่อยๆ 1 เดือนเนี่ย
อาจจะประมาณ
10-15 ครั้งค่ะถือว่าบ่อยเนาะบ่อยบ่อยนะ
บ่อยๆๆอีก 1 ข้อค่ะกูฟ้าได้ค่ะครูหญิงอัน
นี้เนี่ยไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่ 1 เดือนแล้วเอา 1
ปีเลยโว้โอโอ้ 1 ปี
1 ปีนะคะ 1 ปีครูฟ้าเนี่ยใน 1 ปีอีครู
ฟ้าไปหาหมออ่ะ
คุณหมอนะอันนี้คุณหมอ
คุณหมอไปหาหมอแต่ไม่ใช่หมอธรรมดานะคะคุณ
หมอที่เป็นหมอฟัน
นักเรียนอาจจะไม่เข้าใจว่ามันคือฟัน
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยใน 1 ปี 1 ปีครูฟ้าไปหาไปหา
หมอฟันบ่อยแค่ไหนใน 1 ดี
ไม่ 1 ฟรีทุกวัน
[เพลง]
ไม่ในมีนี่ไม่มีครูฟ้าไปหาหมอฟัน
ทุกวันบ่อยๆๆนานๆครั้งน้อยครั้งรั้วใน 1
ปีถ้าไม่ได้ไปหาหมอฟันเลยกุ้งไม่เลยตลอด
ชีวิตนะเท่านั้นอ่ะนี่ก็
จะน้อย
น้อยแบบ
0.5 ครั้ง
อ้าวเพราะว่านักเรียนบางคนเนี่ย 1 ปีนัก
เรียนจะไปหาหมอป่ะเนี่ย 2 ครั้งใช่ไหม 2
ครั้งอันนี้ก็ถือว่าบ่อยๆนะคือถ้าไปหาหมอ
ฟัน 1 ปี 2 ครั้งแน่คือนักเรียนก็ถือว่า
ไปหาบ่อยชาย
ก็คือฟ้าเนี่ยน้อยครั้งนะอย่างที่บอก 0.5
[เพลง]
แล้วก็ผู้หญิงล่ะฮะผู้หญิง 1 ปีครูหญิงไป
หาหมอฟัน
บ่อยแค่ไหนวิ่งไปหาหมอฟันไม่เลยผู้หญิง
ไม่ได้ไปหาหมอฟันเลยใน 1 ปีอันนี้คือ
10.2 เหลือ
ไว้ให้อ่ะ 0 ครั้ง
ไม่ใช่ออกไม่ใช่
0.20 ครั้งนั่งเรียนบอกไม่โอเคนะมาหา
จะกลัวนะคะดูเหมาะกันทรายเราก็มีคำถาม
สำหรับนักเรียน
ถามว่าอะไร
ในใน 1 อาทิตย์ในหนึ่งอาทิตย์นะคะนัด
เรียนเนี่ยดูวีดีโอครูหญิงกับครูฟ้าบ่อย
แค่ไหนดูทุกคนในรูทุกวันผู้หญิงกับกูฟ้า
นะดูบ่อยๆหรือว่าดูนานๆครั้งดูโน้ยครั้ง
หรือไม่ดูเลยหรือดูทุกวินาทีๆ
มา
ดูไม่ได้ค่ะ
ดูทุกวินาทีไม่ก็เม้นบอกเราได้นะคะจะว่า
วีดีโอนี้กูหญิงกับกูฟ้าก็ไปก่อนนะคะแล้ว
เดี๋ยวเราเจอกันใหม่วิดีโอหน้าสวัสดีค่ะ
อ่ะ